[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
débat consacré aux élections municipales
après mon saut bonne cosne-sur-loire
avallon varennes vauzelles et hautain
direction ce soir dijon avec les
candidats encore en lice en vue du
second tour de dimanche avec nous pour
ce débat françois rebsamen bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le maire sortant de
dijon candidat à votre propre succession
vous emmener une liste arrivée en tête
au premier tour avec 38 3% des suffrages
vous êtes membre du parti socialiste
emmanuel bichot bonsoir bonsoir est
membre des républicains tête d'une liste
arrivés deuxièmes au soir du premier
tour avec 19 9% des voix
stéphanie modde bonsoir ou sa tête de
liste europe écologie les verts arrivait
en troisième position le 15 mars dernier
avec 15,1 % des suffrages exprimés alors
six autres listes composent l offre
politique du premier tour à dijon 3
était en capacité de fusionner mais ne
l'ont pas fait trois ont été directement
éliminé
contrairement à d'autres villes où c'est
la crise sanitaire qui s'est invitée
dans la campagne et qui a mobilisé à
dijon les événements survenus au brésil
ces dernières semaines sont un élément
de plus dans le débat politique actuel
ce matin une troisième opération
policière a été menée en moins d'une
semaine suite aux violences urbaines et
aux affrontements survenus à dijon entre
le 12 et le 15 juin alors la question
elle est toute simple françois rebsamen
est-ce que ce qui s'est passé entre le
12 et le 15 juin au brésil c'est
finalement la plus grosse épine dans le
pied de votre campagne
et pourquoi c'est un événement qui a
touché un quartier d'un événement qui
est à la fois dramatique inacceptable et
totalement imprévue puisqu'il n'a même
pas été prévue par le renseignement
territoriales dans les temps et donc un
quartier a subi la violence la vengeance
de
d'un groupe de tchétchènes et jusqu'à ce
que j'obtienne du ministre l'intérieur
castanet christophe castaner des
renforts nécessaires et bien les
habitants de ce quartier qui sont des
gens simples milieux populaires
un beau quartier et bien ils ont été
victimes de ratonnades pour vous la
violence ne vient que de gens de
l'extérieur qui ont attaqué des gens du
quartier des grésillés n'y a pas eu de
riposte il n'y avait pas eu d'attaqué
auparavant il n'y a pas de violence ou
d'armes au sein des grésy je dis pas dit
ça je vous pose la question mais je vous
réponds je n'ai pas dit qu'il y avait
pas de dames c'est vous qui le dites
d'ailleurs y'a des descentes de police
qui trouve aussi des armes factices
incertaine
il ya de tout mais c'est c'est pas
l'armement camp nou dépeignait dans les
dents les réseaux sociaux sur les
réseaux sociaux
l'effet devrait pas passer le débat là
dessus mais les faits sont simples des
voyous ont bastonné un enfant tchétchène
un jeune tchétchène et les tchétchènes
sont doucement se venger et au bout du
bout après trois jours où les
tchétchènes faisait la loi sur ce
quartier bien des jeunes d'autres
quartiers
mais pas uniquement des jeunes des nazis
d'autres quartiers de besançon ii des
mureaux de chenôve sont venus pour une
fois que tu tiennes était parti pour
montrer leur force
voilà exactement ce qu'il en est alors
emmanuel bichot vous on vous a entendu
vous exprimer aussi sur cette affaire et
vous pensé à contrario que il y a des
conséquences locales et des raisons
locales à ce qui s'est passé
écoutez moi je ne crois que
malheureusement le maire sortant est
rattrapé par son bilan dans cette
dernière ligne droite
bien évidemment je pense que la crise
sanitaire a exacerbé toute une série de
problèmes en matière de délinquance et
de trafic de drogue et que c'est peut
être aussi ce qui a accéléré cette
déflagration on va revenir à la question
interne l'instant tout à fait mais ce
que je souhaite dire aujourd'hui c'est
que moi je suis comme particulièrement
choqués par l'attitude du maire de dijon
qui se défausse complètement de ses
responsabilités sur le dos de l'état
alors à l'entendre il n'y a pas de y'a
pas d'armes il n'ya pas de communauté il
n'y a pas de trafic
il n'y a pas de problème tout va bien
dans le meilleur des mondes or néanmoins
nous avons fait la une de l'actualité
nationale et internationale pendant
plusieurs jours
avec une image extrêmement négative et
une situation très grave
moi j'étais lundi soir dans le quartier
des grésillés je peux vous dire que
c'est quand même très choquant de voir
des bandes et des caïds prendre le
contrôle d'un quartier pour bien montrer
qu'ils sont chez eux et qu'ils font la
loi
c'est une situation absolument
inacceptable ce qui est inacceptable
aussi moi je le dis très clairement
c'est que des adjoints du maire de dijon
y compris madame mode qui est adjointe
du maire de dijon ont manifesté quelques
jours auparavant dans une manifestation
avec des slogans tels que tout le monde
déteste la police aucune sanction n'a
été à cet instinct je suis champion n'a
été prise je suis obligé la terreur
monsieur veut simplement dire il ne le
sait pas je réserve humblement dire les
slogans il naissait le monde et des mre
sauvant le monde dernier la bâloise
je voulais demande base de ce qui vient
de nous avons des folies à nos mamans
sont la redresse comme toi c'est comme
vous voudrez c'est plein de photos avec
vos adjoints et les faux avec ses noms
de vérifier avec cette bande demandé
tout le monde déteste la police bien sf
je vous ai demandé d'ailleurs de l'un
par là je vous accordais d'ailleurs de
les remettre dollar était brouillée je
leur ai demandé je vous ai demandé
d'ailleurs donné de les remettre au pas
alors en ce qui concerne rapidement
rapidement
oui on se répond laissés sur cette
question est oui d'accord alors c'est
pas nul à leur niveau non mais je
termine sur ce point parce qu'il est
extrêmement grave
il ya quand même un adjoint du maire de
dijon qui a appelé à la démission du
préfet et du procureur de la république
cet adjoint est toujours en place alors
j'ai demandé qu'il soit sanctionné on
vous a entendu on va laisser stéphanie
mains de répondre vous relations le
défendre l'ordre républicain le maire et
doit être en première ligne
il est garant des institutions pour
stéphanie modde allait très bien il ya
plusieurs choses à qui sont en train
d'être mélangés il ya eu effectivement
non pas une manifestation d'ailleurs
mais tout simplement un rassemblement un
moment donné comme il ya pu y avoir
notamment suite à ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis
tout simplement parce que comme en
france ou ailleurs il faut effectivement
qui est le respect de tous et de tout
dans le respect de la république
voilà ça c'est une chose donc moi
j'étais là effectivement pour manifester
le fait qu'il fallait tout simplement
faire respecter la loi dans notre pays
et pour tous et tous donc ça c'est un
point ensuite ce qui s'est passé déjà au
centre ville de dijon puisque ça a
commencé par par la place de la
république
moi déjà en tient tout entière s'en
tient soutien entier à la population
effectivement des grésy
il ya de gens qui à 99 9% enfin j'ai pas
de chiffres exacts mais qui n'aspire
qu'à une chose c'est pouvoir vivre
décemment tranquillement dans leur
quartier voilà et ils ont vu déferler
effectivement des gens arrivent en
voiture extrêmement menaçant il ya une
rixe au départ avec effectivement une
explication et alzonne qui s'est
retrouvé à l'hôpital ce qui est déjà
totalement scandaleux ça arrive
malheureusement et ensuite une
communauté des gens qui se sont
rassemblées par le biais des réseaux
sociaux et qui ont déferlé sur dijon
dans ce qu'on peut regretter d'une part
c'est qu'effectivement il n'y a pas eu
anticipation et qu'une fois qu'ils
étaient là ils aient pu rester autant de
jours à dijon sans que rien ne se passe
donc c'est un manque d'effectifs de la
police nationale
je suis désolé c'est monsieur sarkozy
qui le premier a commencé à faire
baisser en nombre conséquent le nombre
la police nationale a changé aussi ses
missions ce qui fait qu'actuellement sur
dijon on n'a pas pu anticiper le fait
que ces personnages des individus qui se
revendique d'ailleurs qu'une communauté
moi je pense que c'est pas le souci là
qui se revendique d'une communauté qui
ont décidé qu'il n'est faire la loi
parce que soi-disant la république n'est
pas en état de le faire
donc moi ce que je demande c'est que la
police nationale que l'état le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
que d'une part la police nationale
puisse effectuer l'ensemble de ses
missions
effectivement ça a été dit aussi pour
faire du renseignement pour savoir
précisément quels sont la portée des
agissements de ces individus qui ont
créé la terreur sur ce quartier des
grésillés j'étais aussi là le lundi soir
c'est vrai qu'en réponse est une réponse
complètement disproportionné avec des
armes réelles ou factices mais c'est
vrai que de voir des kalachnikovs celle
là vraiment chaud temps durant ce mandat
vous avez déjà fait des demandes de
police supplémentaires de renfort est ce
que c'est toujours le même problème
parce qu'on est loin quand même du
caillassage de tramway la wii enfin tout
commence par le caillassage de tramway
elle est donc il est clair que on ne
doit pas tolérer des faits de
délinquance et dijon est une ville
paisible par rapport à d'autres villes
les faits de délinquance c'est 57 pour
pour 10000 habitants 57 fait délinquance
pour dix mille habitants
là où ses 140 à a3 et 190 à toulon par
exemple en quoi bien que dijon est une
ville paisible mais c'est une ville
paisible et on est pénalisé d'être une
ville paisible paisible c'est à dire que
l'on retire les effectifs de police sous
nicolas sarkozy que soutenait avec force
monsieur michaud ces treize mille postes
de policiers qui ont été supprimés c'est
les renseignements généraux qui ont
disparu il a fallu recréer tout cela est
donc aujourd'hui
nous manquons a dit jean-louis nous
manquons clairement je demande que la
police nationale soit renforcée parce
que c'est à la police nationale
d'assurer la sécurité des personnes et
des biens la mesnie sibérien et ils font
un travail formidable formidable avec
les moyens dont ils disposent ils
sortent de la crise des gilet jaune
monsieur michaud pour faire peuple
portage et les jaunes
au début la oublier ensuite ils ont eu
toutes les grèves les manifestations
contre il a fallu qu'ils assurent la
sécurité
ils l'ont fait et donc ils sont
aujourd'hui on l'a bien compris ils sont
à bout on l'avait compris que les
questions de sécurité sont du domaine de
l'état néanmoins est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que celui qui sera maire ou
celle qui sera maire demain peut agir
d'une façon ou d'une autre pour limiter
pour éviter que ces problèmes se
reproduise en un mot que je donne la
parole à monsieur michaud derrière bien
sûr commencer par monsieur les choses
maintenant c'est moi qui mets réponse
oui mais c'est vous qui c'est vous qui
êtes aux commandes et de monsieur deux
filles depuis plusieurs mandats des
choix manga est ce que vous pouvez faire
des choix et des contre-vérités ce que
vous pouvez faire des choses bien trop
chaud pour ça je reprends nous faisons
beaucoup de choses dit nous avons
installé des caméras de vidéoprotection
à peu près partout elles sont reliées un
dispositif central qui aide beaucoup la
police nationale elle en prend la main
d'ailleurs elle en a pris la main
l'autre soir dans son intervention quand
il le peut bien sûr et puis nous avons
recruté des policiers municipaux
nous avons des policiers municipaux et
il dispose d'un certain nombre de moyens
des armes de catégorie b et deux
catégories d pour pour jusqu'à une heure
du matin à portée de la tranquillité
mais la chasse aux dealers l'arrestation
des coupables ces jeunes de la relève
savez vous que la police municipale n'a
lui même pas la possibilité de faire des
contrôles d'identité et vous rendez
compte
emmanuel bichot oui moi je rebondis sur
souvenirs la sécurité c'est une affaire
collective c'est la sphère de la
municipalité et de l'état conjointement
et le maire est garant de l'ordre
républicain sur son dans sa commune moi
ça fait des années que j'observe qu'on
ferme les yeux sur la délinquance dans
les quartiers la petite délinquance les
rodéos la grande délinquance avec la
drogue
tout ça se déroule pas à ciel ouvert
sous les yeux des habitants
et moi je pense à parce qu'effectivement
ce sous les premières victimes de cette
situation et donc moi je pense qu'il
faut des mesures fortes
le monsieur monsieur rebsamen parle de
nicolas sarkozy mais tout ça c'est très
vieux il quand il était ministre de
françois hollande ya pas eu un seul
policier supplémentaire de nation de la
police nationale à dijon faut donc la
police nationale a augmenté quand
monsieur sarkozy était ministre de
l'intérieur
les effectifs ont rebaissé quand il
était président les malheureusement
depuis on en est resté là bien mais
c'est pas le sujet parce que qui est
responsable de la police municipale
c'est le maire de dijon alors qu'est-ce
qu'on rentre 2012 avez vous conscience
mais bien mais on est là par les
propositions vous dire tout de suite que
je ferme et juste simplement pour
terminer la police municipale de dijon a
baissé de 25% entre 2012 et 2016 à
contretemps de l'augmentation de la
délinquance alors les solutions elles
sont simples et heureusement nous les
avons pas ce qu'il faut reprendre la
situation mais on peut pas laisser
l'image de dijoux se dégrader comme ça
alors qu'on l'a fait les propositions
d'abord cité de renforcer la police
municipale la police municipale
aujourd'hui dimensionné pour une ville
de 50 mille habitants nous voulons
augmenter ses effectifs de 50 % nous
voulons qu'elles soient armés nous
voulons qu'elle soit présente
de jour comme de nuit parce que après
une heure du matin il n'y a plus
personne donc de la police municipale
dans la rue nous voulons également à
contrat local de sécurité avec l'état
dans lequel on s'engage sur une fermeté
à l'égard de la délinquance on a trop
fermé les yeux pendant des années dans
les quartiers
cette ce contrat local de sécurité sera
aussi un engagement de moyens avec une
augmentation de la police municipale
mais également de la police nationale à
temps pour les autres thèmes va
permettre à laisser au sol à la police
nationale de se recentrer sur ses tâches
prioritaires
nous souhaitons nous souhaitons
également de responsabiliser les
familles et nous souhaitons rétablir des
gardiens assermentés dans les immeubles
hlm
stéphanie mones vous avez des
propositions est ce que vous vous sentez
comme étant membre de la majorité
sortante aussi responsable de tout ce
qui se passe et est-ce que vous avez des
propositions sachant que chez europe
ecologie les verts les questions de
sécurité c'est pas forcément c'est votre
cheval de bataille une préoccupation
notamment
le maire de grenoble a beaucoup de
choses à dire sur ce sujet là et dit
élus écologistes donc non sur le sujet
la tranquillité publique bien évidemment
encore une fois ce qui s'est passé à
dijon aurait pu se passer ailleurs très
sincèrement je ne pense pas que ce soit
ça c'est là ça pourrait se passer
ailleurs il ya eu des exactions de
l'établissement bref donc par rapport à
ça effectivement la tranquillité
publique c'est du ressort de la police
de c'est du ressort de la municipalité
donc la police municipale non l'armée
coûté très sincèrement il n'aurait rien
pu faire sur ce qui s'est passé là c'est
je ne mettrais mois passés sur
certainement pas en danger la police
municipale à les envoyer au milieu de ce
qui a pu se passer au brésil où
centre-ville donc hors de question par
contre effectivement une municipalité on
agit effectivement en prévention donc
une police de proximité des îlotiers
effectivement des gardiens d'immeuble
supplémentaires en lien avec les
bailleurs sociaux
c'est aussi une justice pour ma part les
la police nationale et ce signe justice
qui doit travailler à un rythme beaucoup
plus soutenu donc et dont la justice
pour qu'elle puisse rendre beaucoup plus
rapidement ses jugements
soyons très ferme effectivement sur la
délinquance quand il ya besoin
et puis aidons aussi à toute l'aide à la
parentalité il ya aussi puis un fléau
qui envahit quand même ces quartiers là
et que n'arrive pas malgré la politique
de la ville elle reste tout ce qu'on a
pu mettre en place sur l'habitation etc
c'est vraiment la question de l'emploi
il faut vraiment recréer de l'emploi
dans ces quartiers là pour que tout le
monde puisse être occupés plus qu'on
puisse vivre décemment et ceux qui
choisissent l'argent facile et blanc
pour encore sévir beaucoup on va
reparler évidemment d'emplois dans
quelques minutes suite à l'autre élément
qui s'est invité dans cette campagne
électorale c'est la crise sanitaire sans
précédent que nous avons vécu avec cet
entre deux tours inédits de 15 semaines
stéphanie modde est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'avoir été associée
pleinement par le maire sortant aux
décisions qui ont été prises pendant
cette crise sanitaire est ce que ça
s'est fait en dialogue avec les autres
candidats avec les élus d'opposition et
c'est ce qui s'est passé déjà sûr sûr
sûr cette période de confinement ont
cessé un état quand même un peu de
sidération et un arrêt total de toutes
les activités donc moi je salue encore
une fois le civisme dont a pu faire
preuve l'ensemble des français et 10
et particulièrement puis c'est ce qui
nous préoccupe aujourd'hui dire
également que pendant les quinze
premiers jours effectivement il fallait
prendre des décisions rapides il y avait
il fallait il fallait pouvoir agir moi
je regrette juste effectivement qu'on
était obligé de demander à participer
davantage pour pouvoir être mis au
courant et moi j'aurais souhaité être
associés beaucoup plus
d'ailleurs je vais répondre jean profité
pour répondre à une attaque j'entends
que je trouve extrêmement basses mais
bon c'est comme ça de dire qu'à un
moment donné il fallait que je
démissionne de mes fonctions d'adjointe
moi je pense que ça aurait pu être
reprochés sont réduites me reprocher
d'ailleurs s'il avait décidé en pleine
crise de confinement de dire je laisse
tout tomber serait une démission donc
nous avons été force de proposition
quant il est des réunions nous errons
haïti nous avons connu un cas social aux
réunions nous y sommes allés j'aurais
souhaité peut-être qu'on ait
effectivement notamment un premier
conseil municipal le dématérialisé un
peu plus tôt voilà donc après on a
participé à tous cas qu on a fait des
propositions sur plusieurs sujets sur
les pistes cyclables mais également avec
d'autres effectivement sur la
réouverture des parcs et jardins va te
tape donc quand on a été sollicités on a
répondu on a travaillé sur le programme
qu'on a pu enrichir en scène emmanuel
bichot même question comment vous avez
vécu cet entre-deux-tours un peu
particulier est ce que vous avez eu
l'impression de pouvoir continuer à
faire campagne d'une façon ou d'une
autre ou de pouvoir participer à
l'action de la municipalité à l'écouté
nous nous avions suspendu notre campagne
temps de les circonstances
moi ce que je regrette c'est que la
municipalité en fait s'est contenté du
service minimum dans cette crise n'a pas
suffisamment anticipé les différentes
étapes est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui je
pense que nous avons pris beaucoup de
retard
les différentes étapes pour les
connaissent et de la solidarité avec les
personnes les plus vulnérables c'est la
mise à disposition de masquer la
réouverture des écoles et c'est aussi le
soutien aux entreprises à la reprise
économique qui aujourd'hui a pris
beaucoup de retard
mais moi ce que j'observe c'est que le
maire de dijon à confisquer la
démocratie durant cette période il a
continué à faire sa campagne électorale
avec les moyens de la ville et nous
avons demandé à plusieurs reprises
maintes fois la réunion du conseil
municipal et la réunion du conseil de
métropole figurez vous que le conseil de
métropole ne s'est pas réuni depuis
décembre 2019 ça fait plus de six mois
comment voulez vous qu'on prenne des
décisions importantes des actions
importantes dans ces conditions donc
nous avons pris beaucoup de retard le
conseil municipal n'a été réuni qu'une
fois avec un ordre du jour
ma liste et encore on nous a refusé la
parole sur un certain nombre de rapports
donc aujourd'hui ce que nous souhaitons
c'est que la démocratie se des copines
et qu'on puisse enfin passer à autre
chose
c'est ce qui va se passer le 28 juin si
un deuxième tour des élections
municipales
françois rebsamen qu'est ce que vous
répondez pas assez de concertation pas
assez d'anticipation non je répondrai
pas parce que sur ce sujet les dijonnais
ils ont vu ce que nous avons fait ils
ont vu ce que la municipalité a fait
pour maintenir le service public à flot
ce service public qui a assuré pendant
toute la durée du confinement la
propreté le service des eaux
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères
ça c'était du travail et moi j'étais au
travail tous les jours
j'étais au travail tous les jours et
j'ai fait ce que la loi me permettait de
faire la loi d'urgence sanitaire dire
que je me suis occupé de nos concitoyens
et dès le début j'ai constaté le manque
de masques nous avions une municipalité
qui était précautionneuse nous avions 60
mille masques d' avance et nous avons
distribué immédiatement aux ehpad
nous avons sauvé des vies en faisant
cela nous tous les ehpad de la métropole
ce avons distribué des masques dès le
début là où il y en avait pas là où tout
le monde a cherché en avons distribué
aux infirmiers de ville aux médecins de
ville aux ehpad partout nous avons
distribué des masques ou si hoarau gens
qui travaillaient parce qu'il y avait
des gens qui travaillaient donc on a
fait tout ça pendant deux mois et demi
et puis à la sortie du confinement
effectivement à la mode l'a dit on a
réuni les présidents de groupe pour voir
comment on pouvait faire on a fait à
nyon du conseil municipal vous savez une
ville je crois que vous avez soutenu le
maire de cette ville
c'est monsieur copé le maire de deux
mots vous êtes melville avec 65 cents
vous avez mal voté pour lui
vous avez eu de voir ou à la primaire
parce que félicitations il y avait les
dents vous il n'a pas réuni le conseil
municipal avant fin mai voyage où il
avait été élu au premier tour et il n'a
pas
nikos et mustapha nous avons réuni le
conseil et nous avons pris des mesures
nous avons pris des mesures nous avons
distribué et il y a participé monsieur
bichot et c'est normal quand même vous
les conseillez mais nous étions tous les
conseillers municipaux tuant veut
distribuer les masques on a distribué un
demi million de masques en avance sur
tout le monde partout et donc voilà nous
avons fait tout ce que nous voyons sur
sa ligne est de confinement et j'ai fait
des vidéos pour informer les dijonnais
elles ont été vues plus de 250 mille
fois et je sais que les dijonnais en
sont satisfaits de ce compte rendu
stéphanie n'était pas de la campagne ça
les vidéos par mois la balle vous pose
la question c'est effectivement après
c'était le rôle du maire dont le rôle
mais en étant candidat bon voilà donc
évident et en première ligne forcément
dans première les alignements voilà
après redire 250000 bon ok on entend ce
qui est ce que je voulais rajouter moi
c'est que cette crise sanitaire n'est
rien n'est pas terminée et que redire
aussi quand même que ces deux mois de
confinement ont permis des prises de
conscience très importante de la
population qui effectivement s'est rendu
compte que des métiers mal payés mal
considérés était essentiel est
essentielle à notre société et
qu'heureusement effectivement nous
avions ces personnels qu'on était dévoué
je pense aux soignants mais également
aux enseignants
fectivement aux personnels de 2,2 de
propreté urbaine
tous ces gens tous ces livreurs aussi
tous ces gens qui ont maintenu le fait
qu'on ait pu s'approvisionner
moi je les salue vraiment pas ce que
c'était c'était dans des conditions
difficiles un moment donné où on se
disait qu'il fallait c'est va être
confiné justement pour éviter une
pandémie est ce que c'est le terrain
stéphanois puisque vous avez la parole
est ce que cette crise sanitaire a
changé votre regard sur la ville votre
diagnostic sur la ville et même
quelques-unes de vos propositions est ce
que vous avez fait évoluer votre
programme en 15 semaines
nous ne tenons notre programme justement
tout ce qui est relocalisation
d'économies tout ce qui est circuits
courts d'alimentation cette crise
sanitaire elle est intimement liée à la
crise climatique et dérèglement
climatique et perte de la biodiversité
puisque on voit bien ce qu'ils on a tous
entendu parler de pangolin de 2,2
d'habitat pas de d'animaux sauvages qui
sont qui sont obligés de sortir de leur
date de leur habitat naturel parce
qu'ils ne sont plus non plus la place
pour le faire
on est jeudi je comprends mais on est
sur les pangolins et là on est sur la
les municipales à dijon presse que ça
c'est parce que sinon est ce conflit
pour gaulin d'un virus infiniment petit
nous amène à une crise sanitaire majeure
et bientôt à une crise économique donc
tout et tout et guy donc ça si on le
comprend pas ça et les citoyens l'ont
bien compris
la convention climat qui s'est terminée
là et qui est de nice et nous donc on
donne raison effectivement sûr sûr sûr
une grande partie de nos propositions
voilà il faut donc revoir nos modes de
vie faut revoir nos modes de déplacement
il faut relocaliser une partie de
l'économie
il ya des tas de mesures donc nous
avions déjà avant et que nous avons
conforté et peut-être effectivement la
question de l'emploi en priorité parce
que c'est une question qui va devenir
effectivement extrêmement présent dans
les mois à venir d'emmanuel bichot même
question est-ce que vous avez changé des
choses que vous avez revu votre
diagnostic
après ce qu'on vient de traverser oui
nous nous avons rapidement décidé
d'actualiser notre projet d'une part
pour identifier les mesures urgentes ou
priaulx prioritaires en termes de
calendrier pour répondre à la crise ont
fait un premier volet de nos projets
actualisé et d'autre part les
changements fondamentaux que nous
souhaitions déjà mais que nous
souhaitons encore plus pour l'avenir
dans ces changements fondamentaux moi
effectivement je dis simplement qu'il
faut changer de modèle urbain la
majorité sortante qui est représentée
ici par deux candidats main dans la main
à défend depuis des années le modèle de
la densification urbaine
je crois que ce modèle était déjà
compromis avant la crise sanitaire mais
pour tous ceux qui ont vécu la crise
sanitaire enfermés dans des immeubles
sans espace de verdure autour et que
d'autres que des immeubles autour et
dans des petits appartements et bien
effectivement on voit bien qu'il faut
changer de modèle urbain avoir une ville
plus aéré une ville plus verte est une
ville plus harmonieux c'est une demande
très forte qui s'est effectivement qui
confortait par ce qu'on a vécu durant
durant la crise il ya un deuxième point
sur la sécurité on ne mesure pas à quel
point le confinement est à exacerber les
problèmes de sécurité dans certains
quartiers et à l'intérieur des immeubles
parce que les trafics se sont reportés à
l'intérieur des immeubles est donc là
aussi je crois que je ne peux ne pensons
pas que les problèmes de sécurité vont
être moindres après le confident
qu'après je pense qu'ils vont être plus
grand embarras par les différentes
raisons donc ça c'est aussi un point
qu'il faut prendre en compte le
troisième point c'est effectivement haut
niveau
économie locale réorientons la commande
publique vers les entreprises locales au
lieu de haut lieu de la donne est
presqu'exclusivement ou majoritairement
des grands groupes
soutenons de l'implantation de nouvelles
activités à dijon ça fait 30 ans que
nous sommes dans la stagnation
économique
eh bien il faut absolument soutenir les
entreprises locales développer des
nouvelles activités accueillir de
nouvelles activités c'est une priorité
il faut utiliser le levier fonciers et
immobiliers de manière très offensive
françois rebsamen dernier point aussi
c'est là je sais sur la gestion puis
voilà
oui la gestion publique on en reparlera
françois rebsamen
on a évidemment des questions sur la
santé sur la protection sociale sur
l'emploi on vous le disait est ce qu'il
faut repenser la ville finalement il
faut qu'il va falloir faire face à
l'urgence d'abord et donc moi je
souhaite quand on a un débat comme ça
dire une chose assez simple quand on
veut être maire d'une ville il faut
aimer la ville mais on n'a pas besoin
d'un chef de la police municipale comme
maire en a besoin c'est quelqu'un qui
porte toutes les tous les quartiers de
la ville tous les habitants de la ville
et donc dijon c'est une ville verte
elle vient d'être classé par le magazine
forbes la première vient l'hiver
d'offres de france je voudrais le dire
donc il y à des arbres un peu partout y
a pas que des singles il ya des arbres
ya beaucoup d'arbres
heureusement d'ailleurs et il va falloir
faire donc face à l'urgence
moi j'ai pas besoin de revoir mon
programme parce que je ne sais pas
exactement quel va être l'impact
financier qui va s'abattre sur la
municipalité j'allais dire sur les
municipalités en france younès qui font
jouer sur la commande publique à des
attendait six mois terminées sur ce
point et donc je ne sais pas moi j'ai
pas été obligé de baisser mon nombre de
policiers municipaux dont les impôts
tout ça le programme conapp qu'on a pris
c'est un programme qui va s'étaler un
peu beaucoup pas du tout suivant l'état
que suivant ce que va nous apporter
l'état pour compenser nos dépenses qu
vide car la première des urgences
aujourd'hui elle est double premièrement
il ya un plan social d'urgence à prendre
un plan de solidarité
il faut absolument venir en aide aux
plus modestes a su au niveau municipal
on peut le faire bien faire les choses
1 millions 3,1 millions 3 tout de suite
je mettrai sur la table 1 million 3 tout
de suite pour aider les plus modestes
dans ce pays parce qu'il faut lutter
contre la pauvreté
savez vous qu'il y a près de 25000
dijonnais 25 millions
ney qui vivent avec moins de 1200 19
euros par mois quand on mesure cela on
sait qu'il faut les aider et je
proposerai certain nombre de
dispositions pour les aider et puis il
ya tout ce qu'on peut faire au niveau
économique pour participer de la relance
les entreprises les commerces à céret
des orientalistes par exemple savoie
savoie qui était dans l'agglomération
beaunoise avant à ladoix serrigny belle
entreprise
bah ils veulent pas rester dans
l'agglomération beaunoise ils veulent
venir se développer sur le sur la
métropole donc on va les accueillir ces
300 emplois à la clé donc il faut
développer les emplois et puis il faut
sauver les emplois et pour sauver les
emplois il faut aider les entreprises et
donc on va mettre un plan qui est en
place aujourd'hui d'à peu près ça
représente dans un premier temps sept
cent mille euros que la métropole vingt
mètres pour accompagner l'aide de la
région et la région et la métropole
on va apporter des aides pour passer
cette période mais la vraie la vraie
question aujourd'hui c'est comment
comment l'état va compenser les dépenses
nouvelles qu'ovide les pertes de
recettes
et si l'état allait qu'on pense beaucoup
on ne changera rien s'il est allé
comment les compense un petit peu on
changera un petit peu sinon on est alors
à un peu plus emmanuel bichot à la
mairie comme on aide les entreprises
alors c'est simple je vais vous dire
d'abord je voudrais dire à monsieur
rebsamen que quand on critique quelque
chose qu'il a pu faire ce n'est pas
critiquer dix jours il faut quand même
pas confondre sa personne et la ville de
dijon où il pas propriétaire nous la
ville de dijon
bon en ce qui concerne les entreprises
moi je vous invite à aller place
grangier ya un panneau de travaux sur la
rénovation du parking grangier il n'y a
pas une seule entreprise dijonnaise il
n'y a pas une seule entreprise de la
région bourgogne franche comté
il n'y a que des entreprises de la
région parisienne où les faire la
préférence locale jeu je pense qu'il
faut effectivement modifié tous les
goûts à l'égard de délégation de service
public que nous avons pour privilégier
les entreprises auxquelles il faut
profiter du relèvement du plafond des
marchés publics simplifiée pour
privilégier les entreprises locales il
faut que nous ayons que la commande
publique soutiennent les entreprises
locales je voudrais dire lanaudière
dépenser 2000 lors du conseil municipal
il faut faire des efforts aujourd'hui
pour sauver les entreprises on a presque
30% des coudes et des commerçants
artisans cafés restaurants qui risquent
de mettre la clé sous la porte
donc il faut il faut les aider nous
avons déposé un amendement au conseil
municipal le 28 mai pour que
l'exonération des droits d'enseignés de
voirie soit prolongé jusqu'au 31
décembre 2009
cet amendement a été rejeté ça fait
partie des premières mesures que nous
ferons voter au mois de juillet
stéphanie madaule les premières mesures
d'aidé économique ont été votés que ce
soit en bureaux métropolitains et
ensuite au dernier conseil municipal à
l'unanimité
donc si nous retrouvons tous bien là
c'est effectivement c'est sur l'urgence
à la fois économique et l'urgence
sociale
comment à partir d'une municipalité on
aide les entreprises et les commerces
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
est-ce qu'il faut supprimer des
générations de droit de terrasse par
exemple pour pour les cafés restaurants
pour qu'ils puissent vivre c'est
revitaliser encore plus c'est davantage
aider davantage le commerce de proximité
levé commerce de centre-ville c'est
conditionner les aides et pas
effectivement parce que comment on peut
aider à une commande plus loquace en
conditionnant les aides avec des clauses
environnementales et sociales donc ça
c'est possible il faut le développer
bien évidemment il faut aussi aller sur
des filières d'avenir des filière
décarbonée
donc il va faire aider en plus des
entreprises qui s'engagent résolument
dans la diminution de leur taxe de lors
de leur bilan carbone
c'est aussi un grand plan de rénovation
thermique c'était déjà un des anges en
avait parlé lors du premier débat c'est
quand même un axe majeur qui à la fois
est vraiment exemplaire en train de tout
ce qu'on peut faire en développement
durable puisque à la fois on a des
emplois locaux donc on fait travailler
la filière du btp
on a d'un autre côté des gens qui sont
dans la précarité énergétique qui vont
pouvoir qui vont enfin pouvoir et payer
leur loyer est payé leurs charges parce
que les charges sont moindres et puis
donc voilà donc c'est tout le
développement d'une filière est
effectivement dernier point c'est en
plus on baisse drastiquement les gaz à
effet de serre donc il ya tout un panel
de 2 à la fois donc d'aider de façon
intelligente des commerçants les tpe pme
et puis aussi de faire venir à nous des
entreprises qui sont des filières
d'avenir de même que pour le tourisme il
va falloir effectivement joué sur un
tourisme beaucoup plus local revoir
peut-être le projet de la cité de la
gastronomie pour qu'il soit beaucoup
plus tournée vers l'alimentation de
proximité de qualité un grand plan
alimentaire territoriale aussi à une
demande forte l'an
moi je retrait dire aussi de moules sur
cette période de confinement une demande
des gens d'avoir des habitants de
pouvoir avoir accès à des filières a dit
à des circuits courts d'alimentation pas
assez de réponses pour le coup donc il
faut redimensionner faut revoir pour
être beaucoup plus volontariste sur le
plan le plan alimentaire territoriales
rené demeter
maraîchères un dernier point sur
l'urbanisme quand même effectivement moi
l'urbanisme rapidement sur la
densification urbaine
le constat effectivement que les gens là
ont eu un manque de nature extrême donc
il faut qu'on revoie effectivement ce
plan local d'urbanisme pour redonner
plus d espace de respiration des espaces
verts ça fait longtemps que je dis ça
fait bien les choses
nous savons que ben non pas tout le
temps sauf que l'a fait le compteur pour
diverses ont peu évolué il ya pour les
espaces verts à dijon mais ils sont très
concentrés sur cet endroit et pas assez
sur alors c'est l'espace vert à dijon
gnl en amour j'ai donné la réponse
dijon est candidate pour être capitale
verte européenne elle est finaliste
quatre villes sont finalistes qui à
dijon grenoble et à turin et à tallinn
et donc j'espère bien que nous allons
être capitale verte européenne
ça cloue le bec pour beaucoup un moment
je propose de parler de stratégie et des
lectorats puisque vous le savez il ya un
chiffre qui est inquiétant c'est celui
de l'abstention plus de 64% au premier
tour à dijon un chiffre très important
françois rebsamen comment on fait
revenir les gens dans les bureaux de
vote alors que il ya il ya toujours
cette inquiétude qui plane et peut-être
ce désintérêt aussi à maintenant on leur
dit d'abord qu'il ya un deuxième tour
des élections dimanche 28 juin quand
j'ai vu que 30 % des français ne
savaient pas j'étais assez effrayés faut
dire qu'on vit une situation totalement
exceptionnel cinq mois d'interruption
quatre mois d'interruption donc en est
aujourd'hui responsable et un réseau
donc il faut qu'on fasse face pour faire
face fois dire ils pourront voter dans
les meilleures conditions sanitaires
nous avons distribué 250 mille masques
sans créer 1,4 go vide et donc on peut
venir votre il faut les mettre en trois
lettres on peut venir voter et on peut
avoir des masses quand les distribuera
si ya pas de masques à l'entrée pour
quelqu'un qui veut venir voter et donc
on va faire tout ce qu'on peut pour
mobiliser les gens on essaie de le faire
avec vos débats il faut que les gens
viennent voter très important de voter
pour les élections municipales
alors on veut
vous situez aussi sur le plan électoral
les uns et les autres emmanuel bichot il
ya des choses qui se sont déroulées
pendant cet entre deux tours qui a duré
quinze semaines notamment le candidat de
la république en marche la tête de liste
de la république en marche qui a décidé
de vous soutenir ce n'est pas le cas
d'autres membres de sa liste je le
précise est ce que aujourd'hui vous êtes
le candidat du pouvoir en place avec 7
je vais vous dire ce soutien ce qui
apparaît entre les deux tours c'est que
nous sommes la seule liste avoir reçu de
nouveaux soutiens est dans une dynamique
d'élargissement
donc effectivement vous l'avais dit il
ya de plusieurs listes qui ne pourront
pas concourir au deuxième tour ça veut
dire que le corps du changement le camp
du changement est majoritaire sur la
base si on regarde les chiffres du
premier tour
62% des dix jeunes et souhaite un
changement de municipalité est bien
secours du changement nous sommes les
seuls à pouvoir le porter à vous parler
de sécurité à pouvoir le réaliser c'est
que vous visez aussi les électeurs du
front du froid du rassemblement national
qui n'est pas un jeu quand je parle des
arts écurité je vis tous les dijonnais
tous les dijonnais ont le droit à la
sécurité et à l'ordre républicain
moi je suis très choquée que la paix
civile maintenant qu'on soit obligé de
s'en remettre à un imam proche des
frères musulmans pour rétablir la paix
civile a dit joue il y a un gros
problème de démission de l'ordre
républicain
donc si vous voulez aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une dynamique à
rassemblement très large domination mais
c'est vous qui le dites de la république
en dance jusqu'à ce que l'ordre public
assez le monopole d'un parti politique
mais moi je représente la droite
républicaine un rassemblement de la
droite et du centre
mais qui réunit des dix jeunes et de
toutes sensibilités qui souhaitent le
changement sur sur des bases claires
voilà et donc aujourd'hui nous sommes
les seuls à avoir cette dynamique pour
le deuxième tour stéphanie modde vous
vous êtes aujourd'hui en phase de
françois rebsamen c'était vous auriez pu
être aussi avec lui dans un deuxième
tour ça n'a pas été possible
non ça n'a pas été possible moi ce que
je voudrais dire c'est que neuf nous
avons énergie je pense notre notre notre
électorat parce que plus que jamais
l'écologie est au coeur du projet
politique et que l'écologie ne se fera
pas sans les écologistes que nous avons
l'antériorité que nous avons des
propositions et que je pense que france
entière nous allons avoir des belles
surprises de ce côté là
et comment on ferait pour continuer à
exister quand on a été dans la majorité
de françois rebsamen dans aussi aux
indes en rouge et ont proposé un projet
comme je suis un trader la différent il
est vous retrouverez dans l'opposition
nécessairement par écouter oui si c'est
nécessaire bien sûr ce serait dans
l'opposition une opposition constructive
keira quand il faudra dans le bon sens
et qui sera dire un certain moment
qu'effectivement ça ne va pas par
exemple sur le paie lui acheter donc
voilà ensuite très sincèrement pour que
les électeurs ont envie de venir
il faut effectivement qu'on est aussi un
changement dans la gouvernance ya une
méfiance envers le politique comme le
politique al méfiance en fer envers les
habitants
donc il faut absolument qu'on nous
ramenions les citoyens au coeur de nos
projets soient rebsamen vous avez
renvoyé les verts dans leurs cordes il
ya eu des alliances incroyable dans
certaines villes pour éviter que les
verts arrivent au pouvoir vous n'avez
pas besoin de faire ça on est pas dans
dans les échanges politicien entre les
deux tours ça n'existe pas ça entre les
deux tours n'avait jamais pratiqué non
non je fais pas ce genre de chose depuis
que je suis élu fait une liste au
premier tour et je vais de leurs
électeurs au premier et au deuxième tour
avec la même liste et je suis plutôt
fier et vous aussi vous n'auriez pas pu
espérer convoité les voies de la
république en marché dans le monde dont
on a un programme on a un projet on a
une équipe
un maire un projet une équipe
normalement on doit avoir la majorité
des gens madame messieurs on arrive au
terme de ce débat je vous propose une
minute de conclusion avec le fameux
sabre ibsa billet virtuel qui va
symboliser le temps qui s'écoule durant
soixante secondes derrière nous notre
ordre de passage a été désigné par
tirage au sort juste avant ce débat et
c'est à vous ses fans eamon que revient
la première place pour cette conclusion
cher dijonnaise et 10 jeunes et si je me
présente aujourd'hui en tant
qu'écologiste au poste de maire de dijon
c'est pour faire de vous avec vous de
dijon une ville ancrée dans le 21e
siècle une ville capable d'anticiper et
de résister aux crises à venir quelle
qu'elle soit je souhaite avec vous et
mon équipe que vous soyez vous
entrepreneurs salariés jeunes actifs
inactifs air de dijon une ville unie est
engagée contre toutes les inégalités
sociales et environnementales
une vie où chacun puisse vivre décemment
et en toute tranquillité une vie dont
vous dis jaune et vous êtes les acteurs
avec mon équipe mais également
l'ensemble de la municipalité et des
services
la ville pour adapter nos modes de vie
changement de société oblige
pour répondre au défi climatique une vie
c'est le bon est chaud pour agir
localement efficacement et ne laisser
personne au bord de la route
un autre monde est possible le 28 jean
pour construire ce monde d'après la
seule alternative crédible c'est notre
liste dijon écologique et solidaire pour
transformer l'espoir en en victoire
voilà donc voté pour nous et et pour
dijon écologique et solidaire pouvoir
changer notre société
merci stéphanie modde pour votre minute
de conclusion c'est maintenant au tour
de françois rebsamen ainsi on a désigné
le sort chaire d genèse cher dijonnais
depuis une dizaine d'années dit jean
s'est profondément transformé a beaucoup
changé
tout le monde le sait elle constate
dijon capitale régionale
c'est une ville solidaire à vivre pour
tous une ville universitaire attractive
attractif pour les entreprises une ville
culturelle et sportive reconnue mais
c'est aussi une ville écologique qui est
candidate finaliste pour être la
capitale verte de l'europe après la
crise du coc vide de nouveaux défis
apparaissent aujourd'hui et il faut
savoir les affronter ensemble
pour cela il faut faire de dijon encore
plus qu'elle ne l'est une ville unie
pour se rassembler vous me connaissez
vous pouvez me faire confiance
j'ai cette volonté je les montre et
pendant la crise sanitaire
l'équipe renouvelée et expérimenté qui
m'entourent rassemble des personnes qui
sont des élus à l'image des dijonnais
elle sera efficace et immédiatement
opérationnels aussi le dimanche 28 juin
en toute sécurité sanitaire votez pour
votre mère voter pour la liste dit jean
c'est capital que j'ai l'honneur de
conduire
merci françois rebsamen pour cette
minute de conclusion c'est maintenant au
tour de vous emmanuel bichot pour votre
minutes lyncheurs dijonnaise chars
dijonnais vous aurez dimanche à choisir
entre le maire sortant et moi même au
bout de vingt ans la majorité sortante
dont fait partie madame mode faits sont
en majorité la majorité la minute de
conclusion de la majorité oui mais il
faut que les dijonnais vote utile la
majorité souhaitent les dijonnais
souhaitent le changement
ce changement il faut pas se tromper
d'enjeu est ce qu'on souhaite stopper la
bétonisation pour choisir une ville plus
verte plus aéré plus harmonieuse et ce
qu'on souhaite stopper l'explosion de la
délinquance pour avoir plus de sécurité
et un ordre républicain garantie est ce
qu'on souhaite en finir avec la
stagnation économique pour avoir dû des
activités nouvelles et plus de
développement économique
est ce qu'on souhaite en finir avec la
gestion opaque de l'argent public pour
baisser les impôts et les tarifs publics
dimanche prochain il ne faut pas choisir
en se tournant vers le passé il faut
choisir en se regardant vers l'avenir
voter utile votez agir pour dijon avec
emmanuel bichot pour vous tournez avec
sérénité vers votre avenir
merci emmanuel bichot pour cette minute
de conclusion merci à tous les trois
d'avoir accepté ce débat place donc
maintenant au choix des électeurs ce
dimanche 28 juin
notre soirée électorale se déroulera dès
20h sur france 3 avec et bien des
directs dans les principaux points
chauds de cette élection dijon beaune
montceau-les-mines haute à auxerre sens
varennes vauzelles
nous serons avec vous en direct dans
tous ses points merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis alors attendez la campagne
électorale se poursuit sur france 3
puisque le prochain débat c'est demain
soir à 18 heures avec les têtes de
listes d'auxerre rester avec nous dans
quelques minutes le 19/20 avec marie
joly belle soirée à tous
[Musique]